normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government I
wanted to kind of talk a little bit more
about Disney and and about how the
problems that they've been having um the
uh we were saying that people are being
fired from from movies or I don't know
those Disney movies but because of their
talks about Hamas or Israel or whatever
I'm also concerned that big production
companies um Paramount I don't know call
them out by name if it even matters but
that they have large institutional
investors I don't know if you guys do
too I know that angels are like 100,000
people that all fund the pro program
together mixture it's a mixture a
mixture okay because if proud and
institutional if one big institutional
guy is like listen I my family is in
Israel and I want only pro-israel movies
and propaganda out there right now and
full stop then they're going to pull all
their money from a company that's trying
to make a movie with an actor that's
crapping on Israel potentially and so
these investors are deciding the
creative flow of the movie industry in
that sense or of that industry and
that's a fail man if you can't be as
creative as you want with your best
actors and your craziest ideas good luck
how can you compete with people that are
doing that so how do you guys work with
the institutional to not get co-opted by
the institutional Investments so the
only way to get through Angel is through
the angel Guild so that those 100,000
people Jeffy is the chief content
officer he can't if he had if he loved
your show Ian that you were you were
sharing with us he can't take it there
unless the angel Guild sees it first and
they are like the you know they they can
see
whether something has a problem that's
what the wisdom of crowds is is that
sound of Freedom sound of Freedom was
watched by 30 plus million people
worldwide in theaters because a thousand
Guild members Angel Guild members voted
for that show yep wow so like if a movie
got made with an actor that was making
these comments about Hamas or something
and then but the angel invest or if the
guild was like we still love it put it
through there's some dissent are there
investors that once it gets through
they're like I'm not not going to put
money on that one is that part of the
process they have a choice they have a
choice whether they want to invest in a
project for sure yeah it doesn't it
doesn't guarantee that we'll be able to
get the
film uh to do a partnership with the
film like there's still a lot of things
that happen have to happen after the
guild but we cannot take a film into
Angel Studios until it passes The Guild
and they so there's 100,000 people
they've invested in different projects
they can they go on they they they they
become members of The Guild and then you
get to as a member of The Guild you get
to vote on the stuff that goes to
theaters vote on the stuff that goes on
the platform and if you don't pass it it
doesn't come on Angel and is that the
threshold a thousand people you said a
thousand people a thousand is like tell
statistical significance yeah
statistical significance of the audience
yeah and so you'll have you know a few
hundred to a thousand people watching
each movie there's 21 movies submitted a
week right now to Angel Studios on
average 21 movies a week There's 100
plus thousand people going through these
movies mov voting then they decide what
comes in and then as a guild member when
you become a member of The Guild it's
like an Amazon Prime membership or
Costco membership you get perks like you
get complimentary tickets to every
single movie because you're an angel
executive like oh I was going to say I
like this I like this idea you know
Ian's concern is one guy can be like I'm
shutting your movie down because I don't
like what that person said that's and
exactly I may disagree with these these
these you know people cheering Hamas or
being critical of Israel to varing
degrees um but I do think they have a
right to speak their mind and it is
shocking when a studio says they're
going to shut them down so I like the
idea that with you guys one person can't
just do it it has to be a community
effort so think about this way if you
get a m a lead actor in a film and then
he comes out you know to do press for it
and says a whole bunch of nasty awful
like really shockingly offensive stuff
and then the community says we don't
want to go forward with this project
that that would end the project that
that's what I think that's the way to do
it I'll tell you tell you why not all
speech is socially acceptable if there
was a guy who went out and started
demanding that schools start giving
these books to kids I'm pretty sure a
lot of people will be like no no no no
no no no no like this is not someone we
want to support right that crosses a
line for for something we don't want by
all means he can go do his own thing but
we're not going to Greenline it however
it's not one guy it's a large community
that has to come to a a statistically
significant decision amongst themselves
is there ever is there a cap on
individual investors so that one guy
can't come in with 100 million and be
like I want yeah so the last investment
I think the cap was 10 or is it is it 15
last time I don't know $15,000 I don't
remember the last one that's very small
15,000 I thought you going to say 15
million the the cap now the film was
made with bigger investors but once it
passed the guild and then it took on PNA
money which is the way it did the crowd
money PNA it's called it's prints and
advertising so back in the day
when you prints meant you print out a
reel of film and ship it to every single
theater so that they can play it on
their
projectors prints and then you print out
the the movie posters those were the
prints that cost a lot of money just to
get those out to the world and then
advertising is how you promote and make
awareness around the film So currently
like prints are like a lot of them are
done over satellite and a lot of them
are done little hard drives you still
mail the hard drives yeah to a lot of
them is that just Old Guard like not
figuring out they can email it yet or
yeah yeah they don't have great internet
maybe or their projectors aren't
connected to these are multi-terabyte
movies these are multi-terabyte movies
you you have to have really good
internet in order to to uh to bring down
that level of a film so prints and
advertising are the prints are the
printing out the posters and that stuff
and then advertising and the the the
crowd invests in prints and advertising
they did it for sound of Freedom they
put $5 million to get sound of Freedom
out to the theaters they put it into
after death they put it into his only
son they put it in the shift which is
coming out on December 1st and there's
thousands of people helping these movies
get off the ground and they become Angel
Investors and then once you become an
angel investor you become part of the
guild and you get a vote on the next
content that comes in and you're part of
the the new gate the the you're
replacing the gatekeeper model the old
gatekeeper model and you're right Ian uh
no go the uh in the traditional system
one Studio would cut the check for PNA
and they get a decide and in this one we
want as many checks as possible because
all those people they're part of the the
audience they want to they want to be
part of shaping the culture they're
going to B drag all their friends out to
the movie all their relatives everybody
they can get I think an important
distinction you know uh in the idea of
cancel culture cancel culture was
basically they would dig into your past
find something you said 10 years ago
that either is no longer uh culturally
relevant or now is considered acceptable
and use that to destroy your life or in
the most egregious most egregious
example this race car driver's dad
dropped a racial slur in the 80s before
he was born so a sponsor dropped him
because of it I'm like that's insane but
let's be real you know we had that woman
on culture war and she said I was Pro
censorship because I said I don't want
these these these adult books in in
grade schools and I'm like yes next
question no question whatsoever it it
it's it's it's not this idea that we
think everyone should be able to say
literally anything in our private spaces
or in our industry that we have to
invest in it freedom speech means you
can live your life without government
interference and opposing cancel culture
first and foremost has to do with our
moral basic lines right so what happens
is the woke left comes out and says oh
we we've hereby decided that this thing
is no longer acceptable socially and
you're going to lose your job because of
it or a or talking with this person is
no longer socially acceptable and we're
like dude dude dude what are you doing
firing this person over this stuff these
people are saying things that aren't
even that offensive men aren't women
though and Megan Murphy gets banned from
Twitter for that that that's ridiculous
now if someone went on Twitter and
literally was advocating for violence or
Terror or genocide then we might be like
well okay well now we're getting into
dangerous territory as for like the
calls for extreme violence we've
actually had a great conversation on
this show about the limits of it if
someone is speaking generally about war
and conflict and targeting different
groups we kind of shrug we're like I
look when they when they call for death
to Russians Facebook allows that now if
someone goes on Twitter and just tells
people to in like as as inputs an
imminent threat targeting a group of
people then we say okay that's crossing
the line but my my view is this we
shouldn't tolerate extremist opinions we
like we shouldn't have to pay for them
and fund them I think we can allow on on
and and agree with on social media
platforms a wide range of opinions that
we disagree with and don't like to
challenge but there's absolutely a red
line for all of us where we're like nah
like this is too much and it's like
advocating children be exposed to adult
content things like that probably
crossing the line but the other thing
I'll mention too is I'm not here to be
the Arbiter of morality and tell you
where a system like Twitter should
determine or X where people can and
can't say things my attitude will
typically be let the crazy people say
the crazy things so we can know they're
saying it that being said if an actor
came out and did was advocating for a
whole bunch of really nasty stuff like
getting you know grooming kids and
things like that I certainly would not
want to be involved in a project with
them and I think that's fair that people
would say no to it the big difference is
we're taking back the Overton window
where the left said that saying
something like we should have
immigration controls oh you're you're
canceled you're fired that's what's
crazy that's a reasonable thing to say
yeah I think it is I mean I think part
of the desire to push the window so far
is to obscure the idea of what's right
and what's wrong I think there are a lot
of people who I wouldn't agree with
politically who would also say no I
don't want children exposed to sexual
content at a young age or
inappropriately uh but there is another
narrative especially on the Progressive
left that says oh well maybe you're
oppressing someone by by saying those
ERS are bad or condemning them they they
want there to be no Hardline no uh and I
think they want you to feel more okay
with compromising your values and that's
very that there's no way to uh maintain
a culture if that's also the energy when
I when I first went to college one of my
friends her dad said you can go to
college and keep an open mind but not so
open that your brains fall out M thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net